hallo herzlich willkommen meiner torten
weltweite gibt ein richtig leckeres und
sehr einfaches bisher
ich werde nämlich millibar machen euch
hatte hannover schon mal gemacht es war
aber schon wie schon einige zeit her und
zwar ist paul glover einfach aus einem
baiser teig also aus einer pc masse
praktisch eiweiß und zucker und später
wird es eben gebacken oder gedruckt mit
dem backofen und dann kommt einfach noch
ein bisschen sahne rein und ich mache
noch mal groß schreibt also es wird
richtig wuchtig richtig lecker ist
eigentlich so ein ideales sommergericht
aber ich finde auch jetzt im frühling
darf das nicht viel
vor allem kammer die b&c stücke richtig
gut vorbereiten und musste dann einfach
nur noch firmen zu kurz vorm servieren
und hatte dann fertig ist das her
ich werde jetzt so etwa 15 stück zu
bereiten und zeigt euch einfach mal die
zutaten vor allen dingen kann man halt
hier in der richtig gute resteverwertung
machen wenn man zum beispiel ein eiweiß
übrig hat und konnten beide benutzen
also ich brauche vier mal eiweiß 200
gramm zucker also praktisch pro eiweiß
50 gramm zucker und dann noch einen
teelöffel speisestärke und eine prise
salz also das war's auch schon
zumindest für die pc masse jetzt mache
ich das ganze wieder in einer
küchenmaschine ihr könnt aber auch an
handrührgerät benutzen geht auch gut
ordnung bisschen länger
jetzt gebe ich da hat das eiweiß reihen
und die prise zucker es als
durcheinander und es lasse ich jetzt
erstmal steif schlagen und später kommt
es sogar mit dazu
jetzt ist das eiweiß steif sieht man
einfach hier das half nichts mehr runter
ist alles fest
und jetzt kann ich nach und nach dem
zucker mehl dazugeben und dann muss ich
es aber nochmal etwa fünf minuten rühren
bis sich der zucker einfach aufgelöst
hat er steht bei mittlerer stufe mit der
zu setzen schüler aus der schüssel
rauskommt
sand gleich bei höchsten stufen weiter
rollen
so sieht jetzt meine bc masse aus also
richtig schön fest und glänzend und ich
finde sie immer so lecker aus und könnte
grad dafür wenn es das büro ist eiweiß
werden naja jetzt gebe ich hier noch die
stärke dazu diese jetzt vorher damit
keine klümpchen gibt und die hilft mir
einfach dann auch das ganze so eine
schöne kruste bekommt
und jetzt habe ich das kurz runter
einfach so man könnte jetzt auch
farbstoff zum beispiel zu fügen also
lebensmittel passte oder kakaopulver das
hatte ich auch bei meinem bei meiner
pablo wartete schon gemacht mit schoko
geschmack das war richtig lecker aber
ich lasse es jetzt schön weiß weil ich
bin das passt einfach gut zu den mangos
jetzt habe ich hier einen spritzbeutel
bereits vorbereitet da habe ich jetzt
noch tolle drin
mit 13 millimetern durchmesser und ist
auch ein relativ großer schritt freudl
als soja 50 zentimeter spritzbeutel kam
aber auch in einweg nehmen jetzt schlag
ist da oben so ein bisschen um und kann
hier jetzt die masse einfüllen erinnert
auch total an schnee schmecken besser
ich mache es jetzt auch nicht so voll
damit wird es ihn jetzt sind wieder raus
gewählt und jetzt kann ich das hier
finden so drehen und vorne bereits raus
drücken
wenn ihr jetzt einen spritzbeutel habt
ich das gar nicht schlimm
könnt ihr einfach die baiser massa mit
einem löffel hierauf tragendes teil
besten auch gleich und ich habe jetzt
hier schon eine bank foley vorbereiteten
backpapier geht natürlich auch jetzt
werde ich da kreise drauf spritzen
also ihr könnt euch gerne auf backpapier
auch kreise zu verzeichnen war das
backpapier umdrehen aber das geht auch
so ganz gut jetzt fange ich hier in der
mitte an eine schnecke und die zwei ich
nach oben und bild hier einfach so ein
rand und die mitte bleibt frei denn da
fühle ich dann später machen backen die
sauna ein aber praktisch zu einer
vertiefung schon jetzt mit whistler
abstand gleich das nächste
die gehen 200 auseinander aber höchst
einfacher
und ohne spritzbeutel gebt ihr einfach
so ein esslöffel voll von dieser bc
masse hier drauf einem esslöffel oder
halbtags aber machen und dann wird es
hier so ein bisschen glatt gestrichen
und mit seiner mini palette oder mit
einem kleinen messer kann ich das dann
so ein bisschen rund formen haben sie
also ein bisschen eine andere form und
in die mitte drücke ich dann einfach so
eine mulde rein also das geht auch gut
und den letzten rest spritzt sich hier
einfach noch drauf das kann man nämlich
nicht mehr so gut formen dem
spritzbeutel dann freue mich dass auch
noch aus oder ihr könnt einfach so
kleine baisse tiefs spritzen und die
einfach fertig backen und später
vernaschen
jetzt könnt ihr auch zwei verschiedene
datenbanken entweder bei umluft bei 110
grad für 30 minuten so mache ich das
jetzt gleich oder ihr macht bei ober und
unterhitze bei ungefähr 140 grad da
braucht man einfach bisschen mehr
temperatur für etwa 35 bis 40 minuten
und danach werde ich den backofen
einfach ausschalten und sie im backofen
abkühlen lassen und ich kann jetzt beide
bereiche gleichzeitig rein stecken denn
ich mache das jetzt bei umluft
meine bc stückchen sind jetzt abgekühlt
und so sehen sie jetzt aus also außen
sind so richtig knusprig und im innern
sind sie so ein bisschen wie so eine
marshmallow masse also dass ein bisschen
feucht und die das jetzt hier einfach
stehen und werde mich schon mal um die
füllung kümmern und zwar mache ich eine
sahne und dazu kommt noch ein bisschen
frucht damit mittel gefunden und ich
brauche jetzt für die füllung 400 gramm
sahne
ihr könnt auch gerne mischung aus sahne
und quark nehmen zum beispiel dann
brauche ich ein bisschen salat zum sahne
streifen so etwa drei bis vier teelöffel
für den geschmack ein bisschen vanille
ich nehme jetzt auch keinen zucker weil
die bse massagen süß genug ist und dann
noch für die deko und paar kokosraspeln
gerne auch cocos chips weiße schokolade
und eine mango als frucht ich fange
jetzt direkt mit dem mango an und wächst
jetzt erstmal scheel also normalerweise
mache ich da immer so dass ich das hier
erst runter schneide und dann auf klappe
und die mango eben würfel aber ich
möchte keine würfel sondern uns ein paar
spalten
deswegen stehe ich da ist die schale
runter
nehme ich mir ein großes messer und
jetzt liegt im innern der mango ebenso
ein riesen kerns und flacher kehren und
da versuche ich jetzt ein bisschen dran
vorbei zu schneiden also wenn ihr merkt
schon widerstand müsste einfach mit
messer dran vorbei man sieht dem kennt
hier auch auf der anderen seite genauso
den glitschig deswegen müsste da echt
aufpassen im netz das internet abrutscht
so die reste die jetzt darauf noch
länger als auf dem kern werde ich gleich
noch abschneiden und setzte gleich zu
einem curie verarbeiten das benutze ich
dann nämlich auch glücklich und diese
zwei hälften werde ich jetzt in dünne
spalten schneiden
die nämlich später für mich darüber
legen
die langen halme ich jetzt hier also den
anfang und das ende habe ich jetzt bei
weggenommen damit einfach nicht so lang
wird und es setzt sich jetzt hier auf
eine platte man kann das hier so ein
bisschen ausruhen
limango ist es schon gut aber da könnte
noch jede angefügt nehmen oder ja also
mango ist so ein bisschen exotisch aber
man kann wirklich jeder andere frucht
nehmen also mein favorit sie noch etwa
und himbeer weiß nicht was fällt dir
dazu ein gleich ein großer heidelbeer
fällen dann vielleicht auch eine oma vor
allem mit der farbe richtig gut aber da
kann man wirklich echt alles nehmen
schmeckt alles gut hauptsache gesund
oder genau habt auch eine gesunde frucht
egoismus er rechtfertigen
und den rest hier schneide ich jetzt
einfach gut und wenn es dann gleich
pürieren
jetzt habe ich mir hier so ein paar
mango reste weg gelegt die gebe ich
jetzt hier in mein glas mixa können doch
meinen pirat machen aber das ist so eine
kleine menge deswegen mache ich das
jetzt sicher in der gewürzmühle und ich
gebe da noch ein bisschen saft dazu ihr
könnt auch wasser mitzunehmen
ich habe keine anderes presse also mache
ich das jetzt so hindemith so ein
bisschen blutorange weil ich keine
normale orange habe aber es geht
wirklich alles alles können kinder und
maracujasaft zum beispiel nehmen alles
was euch schmeckt aber ich find farblich
sollte es halt so bittel passen
das hurrikan gibt es hier einfach stehen
lassen gebe jetzt mein vanille extrakt
die zur sahne mit dazu und schlagt die
sahne steif und gibt währenddessen
einfach vom sanner park mit dazu am
besten er später stufe
gemeinsam ist jetzt steif geschlagen und
jetzt nehme ich mir ein teelöffel und
füllt damit diese bc kuchen einfach ein
ein bisschen ein bisschen obendrauf
da dürfte jetzt auch nicht zu arg
sparsam sein kapitel sahne mit dabei
haben nämlich von dem fruchtpüree und
gibt es hier so drüber damit dass ein
bisschen runter läuft
das bringt das nicht lecker ausgeht
dann ein paar cocos raster
und ein bisschen weiße schokolade die da
habe ich jetzt weiße kuvertüre können
aber auch normale schokolade nehmen und
die habe ich jetzt ein bissel mit messer
runter einfach so obendrüber schaltet
sie das und die sehr geehrter kann das
ein bisserl angeben also das könnte
schon vorbereiten und dann etwas was
hübsch aussieht und mal ganz anders
schmeckt ohne kuchenteig und hat richtig
leicht und jetzt unsere mango
dann noch in minsk das ist so ein
bisschen für die optik und ich gehe
jetzt noch meine chips obendrauf ein
bisschen nebendran ich finde einfach
dass kokos ist echt gut zudem zu der
mango pass macht es ganz recht so
richtig exotisch und dann ist es dass er
auch schon fertig und wir probieren das
jetzt gleich mit der karim o aber ich
freue mich hier noch kurz auf und dann
probier mal zugleich stellen wir uns
jetzt alle vier kokosnussschalen an
genau uns fehlt einfach das passende
outfit partnerlook
wir probieren sie ich habe die große
ehre
du darfst schön und wie ist das jetzt
also eigentlich wäre sehr gut wenn man
die mangos so in würfel schneiden weil
dann kann man sehr gut laufe ein kalter
zeit jetzt in spalten geschnitten damit
schüler aus zählt bei amazon
am besten so von oben runter
weißt du dran ich denke also nicht nur
wenn man es anschaut sondern jetzt
andere probiert ich denke an sommer
sonne strand total und so locker leicht
man kann man einfach gut beim essen sie
zwar nicht mehr so schön aus aber muss
ein bisschen die mango kleinmachen
probieren und erreicht echt komplett die
süße vom pc aus man muss in die saane
echt gar nicht nach süßen und dem motto
passt perfekt
sehr lecker essen das jetzt hier noch
auf ihr dürft das rezept nachlesen auf
selb - blog.de und wenn ihr es nach
macht auch gerne mit anderen früchten
freue ich mich wir nehmen wir ein foto
auf instagram oder facebook schickt bis
zum nächsten mal anstrengend ja genau
bei zehn grad